on the other end of suffering is a life
that many people don't know even exist
It's A Beautiful World we all live in
this world where our brains are keeping
us in this box outside that box on the
other edge of suffering is a world
that's endless of opportunity but we are
afraid to go outside that box because in
that box is comfortable outside that box
man God gives you a shovel and says Man
start digging that's not fun so what
wall are you climbing now man right now
I've climbed a lot of walls there's no
more walls anymore the reason why is cuz
I know how to climb I'm good I'm not
scared to climb anymore I go to the Rock
hammered in I got my bade and I'm good
to go so you got to figure out how to
climb first and that's all we all have a
different way of climbing we all have to
strengthen our mind to figure out our
own equation once you figure out your
own equation in life you can then start
picking away at how to be better but you
first have to figure out your equation
in life once you figure that out man you
can do anything hey it's EV Carmichael
and I make these videos because I need
them because I want to wake up every
single day and get pushed by somebody
who's doing a lot more than me and in
watching their videoos videos it
inspires me to be bolder to have more
courage and go chase down the life of my
dreams and I hope it does the same for
you so today let's get inspired with
some of the best motivational speeches
so far this year
enjoy your mind is so powerful and I
didn't realize it I went through three
hell weeks Ranger school Delta Force
selection all this stuff this incident
I'm going to explain to you right now
was where I realized we are only at 4
40% of what we are capable of here I am
brought idea to do this race called
badwater
135 I Googled the 10 hardest races in
the world what came up crazy race in
Death Valley summertime 135 miles I knew
nothing about ultra running I thought
you would like you know camp out run 20
miles then one day and then run 20 miles
again until he got 135 miles had no idea
what I was doing called the race
director up he's like hey have you run a
100 miles I was like what in a week or
what what you talking about he's like no
in 24 hours or less I said no he goes
you got to qualify to get in this race
you have to run a 100 miles in 24 hours
or
less he was trying to call my bluff I
call him up on a Wednesday he goes hey
there's a race in San Diego on
Saturday where it's a 24-hour race where
you run around you know a track a 1em
track for 24 hours and if you get 100
miles I will consider you in my
race it really helps to be smart people
and I was not smart in this situation I
said oh I did the math it's about a 14
something in mile I can do
that anyway I show up on Saturday with
the blue lawn chair Rich crackers mlex
and my ex-wife and every mile I'm going
to see her I'm going to grab some Ritz
crackers and some mylex I don't know
what the hell I'm doing but it's Bliss
that whole ignorance is bliss thing so I
get to 70 miles pretty damn fast I get
to 70 miles in like 12 13
hours what you think happens to your
body when you haven't trained for that
kind of mileage a lot of bad things but
I thought I was in good shape it was
amazing so I hadn't gone to the bathroom
at all I sit down big
mistake I sit down this blue lawn chair
I sit down looking at my ex-wife I'm
seeing like three or four of her I'm
like oh this is not good so I'm trying
to play it off because I know where I'm
about to
go so I'm sitting there and we haven't
gone the bathroom you're dehydrated your
nutrition's all jacked
up you sit down you got go to the
bathroom now so I look at my ex-wife I
go do you love me she said yes why I go
cuz I want to take a out myself
right now CU I can't stand up cuz my
blood pressure is all messed up so I'm
sitting there
literally pooping up my back and peeing
blood down my
leg she's a nurse so she's
concerned
and I'm telling you right now there's
one thing you never want to hear as a
black
person she said you're starting to turn
white so I'm sitting there and I'm all
jacked
up and I'm like
okay how in the world am I going to I
got 30 miles to
go I should quit but I
didn't what I started doing through this
whole process was I started to study
myself in the dark times so instead of
just quitting real
fast I said you know I'm going to quit
but not right now so I sat back for a
second and I said let me get some water
let me hydrate let me clean myself up a
little let me get some
nutrition I wasn't
dizzy said okay my feet are all messed
up let me see if I can
walk I'm going to walk one mile and then
I'll go home that' be a great
accomplishment for me 71
miles so I took this massive thing and I
started breaking it down in this small
chunks and as I started breaking it down
to small chunks I started
realizing maybe I'll walk one more mile
but at the pace I was walking I wasn't
going to make the time so this is when I
realized that whole 40% rule those of
you who were you know R can't hurt me
you understand it basically the 40% rule
is when we have a governor on our brains
like a governor on a car a car may say
130 but if you put a governor on a car
you only go 101 we do the same thing to
our brains I was born with limited
Horizons born in other side of the
tracks I didn't think I could be anybody
so my governor was
myself so once you take that governor
off you have Limitless Horizons speech
number two is put in the work with Tom
Bilu listen and listen well because no
truer words are ever going to be
spoken you can do anything you want
without limitation whatever it is that
you decide you want to make come true in
your life you can do that it is going to
take an inhuman amount of work you're
going to have to be prepared to break
yourself in half you are going to have
to learn more than anyone has ever
learned you're going to have to push
yourself harder than anyone has ever
asked you to push yourself before you're
going to go Way Beyond your Breaking
Point you're going to run until you
vomit you're going to study until you
fall asleep you're going to push and
push and push and then you're going to
push some more and when you hit the
limit you're going to push again beyond
that you're going to force yourself into
an adaptation response and
why because as Malcolm X said the future
belongs to those who prepare for it
today so if you don't put the work in
today if you don't do the unending back
breaking work of developing yourself
into something greater the world is
going to pass you by the people that are
going to own it are going to be the ones
that did that work and the one promise
that I can make you right now is that
somebody somebody out there is
outworking somebody right now is doing
the things that I'm saying somebody
right now is doing the work of failing
and getting up and getting better and
pushing themselves and triggering that
glorious adaptation response that makes
humans the apex predator someone right
now they're putting in that work and if
you don't the future is going to belong
to
them and as Martin Luther King Jr said
if you can't fly then run if you can't
run then walk if you can't walk then
crawl but whatever you do you have to
keep moving
forward it's not okay to make it excuses
it's not going to slow people down it's
not okay to ask the world to stop so
that you can step out front it's not
okay to expect little of yourself and
demand great rewards the only thing
that's okay is to be in line with the
way that the world really works and if
you want to be great you've got to
become capable of greatness you've got
to develop your skill set you've got to
take what you have now and if that's
crawling then crawl but you drag
yourself ever forward to a vision of
yourself that is so clear and so
specific that nothing could knock you
off your path because you my friend know
exactly where you're going you're
willing to pay whatever price it takes
to get there and no matter what anybody
says no matter how many hecklers come
for you no matter how many people try to
throw dirt on you try to stop you try to
knock you down no matter how many people
come for you at night while you sleep
you will rise and you will keep pushing
forward and you will get better every
day and no matter how many times people
chop at you knock you down knock you off
the path you will get back on you will
crawl till you can walk you will walk
till you run and then you will run until
you fly and that my friends is the only
path forward so if you want a future
that makes you happy if you want a world
that you're excited about get your ass
out there and earn it speech number
three is fight your fears with J shett
most of us don't realize that we get
consumed by fear instead of using fear
so fear
becomes our being in the sense that fear
becomes what controls us it tells us
what we should do and what we shouldn't
do it tells us how we should think and
we shouldn't think it stops us from
doing stuff that's really important to
us and it makes us do things that we
would never ever do it makes us say
things to people that we love that we
would never want to say to them and on
the other end it stops you from saying
things you really want to say to someone
because you don't want to appear weak
and your ego won't let you so fear takes
this really magnetic controlling effect
on our whole lives but fear at the same
time can be one of the healthiest things
because it's basically giving you a
signal as to what's important it's
basically giving you as a signal as to
how you feel and when you use it as a
signal not as a suggestion or a push it
changes everything so let's let's make
that practical when you are in your home
and if the fire alarm goes off that
gives you a signal to say check for the
fire check if there's a fire right now
if you go oh just turn it off it doesn't
matter let's let's avoid my fear let's
avoid it let's just turn it off let's
forget about it your house could burn
down or if you're lucky there was
nothing and it's fine but the odds are
that there could be a fire now if you're
someone who goes well let me inspect it
let me be curious about that I am scared
that there's the fire in my house now
that I've heard the fire alarm but let
me be curious let me inspect let me
check imagine we approached our fear in
that way imagine every time I felt
scared of something I said well let me
get curious about this why am I scared
of this why is it affecting me so much
what about this scares me is it all of
it or is it just a part of it when you
start doing it you start to break that
fear down and that's the healthy way of
looking at fear rather than the
unhealthy way of saying forget about it
keep it away from me I don't want to go
there and so for me I really feel that
fear is what blocks us from these
beautiful breakthroughs in life and it
has such a choke hold on us like it has
such a strong hold on us and I think
most of us are living Our Lives because
we're scared of what someone will say
what someone will think or what someone
will do and that feels like something
that we're going to regret when we're at
the end of our Lives also to make sure
you're actually taking action after
watching this video I've designed a
special free worksheet just for this
video the worksheet will highlight all
the Lessons Learned in this video as
well as pull out our three favorite
learnings and quotes that will inspire
you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for for free
there's a link in the description below
go click on it and start building the
momentum in your life and your business
I'll see you there speech number four is
follow your heart with naine Jane no one
should be doing things that they don't
enjoy so I have a very simple rule in my
life as I said I wake up at 4:00 a.m.
and the day I feel when I wake up at
4:00 a.m. I'm not jumping out of the bed
that means I'm doing things I don't
enjoy so rule number one when you wake
up in the morning and if you're not
jumping out of the bed you should quit
what you're doing because that's not
your calling when you find your true
purpose find your you know not star you
can never ever just lie down because
you're
so driven to solve that problem if I may
say you know lot of people talk about
passion I think the passion is for
hobbies passion is for losers the true
winners have Obsession Obsession to
solve the problem not Obsession about
things Obsession to solve the problem
when you're truly obsessed about solving
a problem you go to sleep thinking about
it and you jump out of the bed wanting
to do it and that to me is find
something that you're willing to die for
and live for it find something that
you're willing to dedicate your life to
solving and then solve it right right
and you know lot of people give up
because there are anytime you do
something there are going to be the
times that things not working out
exactly what you expected and to me
that's a sign of you are alive because
you the only way you know when you're
alive because you have a heartbeat and
the heartbeat goes up and down and up
and down and when it is smooth you're
dead so if you're looking for a life
that's a smooth life you're looking for
a life of a dead person find things when
they're going up and down that tells you
alive when you are down just hunker down
and know know that the next beat is
going to be up and when you're on top of
that beat never become too arrogant
because always remember the winter is
coming and winter shall come right and
that is the life is that most people
spend their life thinking they need to
make money so they do something they
don't enjoy guess what when they come
home they cannot enjoy because they
wasted their life doing things they
don't enjoy and they turn the TV on as
you say to switch off their mind and now
they're being bombarded with the most if
you're watching news unfortunately it's
all about negativity for many reasons
our mind our am migdaliz looking for
negative news so negative News catches
our attention and that's the reason
newscasters know to get your attention
if it bleeds it leads they want to talk
about all the negative stuff so you're
bombarded and now you're even more
negative than you were at work and the
thing in life is to get yourself out out
of that
mode not only find your purpose but
truly be grateful for the life you're
living in speech number five is don't
fear failure with Gary Vee everybody in
the world has
failed there's not a single person that
hasn't failed a lot of times the quicker
you get comfortable with losing the
quicker you're going to have a happy
life you don't want to lose it's not
necessarily what you're trying to do but
not all losses are really losses they're
just step backs they're just little
moments in time and they're always an
opportunity to learn and understand and
so I highly recommend you understand
that losing is a part of life one of the
biggest mistakes that grown-ups
sometimes make is trying to protect kids
from
losing losing is a part of life and the
quicker you get comfortable with it the
quicker you're going to have a happier
life I don't like losing but I know it's
a part and when I lose I try to reflect
on what I could have done better and
then I try to bring that energy to the
next time so that's what you have to
really realize it's just a part of life
just like the sun coming up and going
down and the moon coming up and going
down you will lose you will get bad
grades you will lose a sporting game
like you'll have a bad day you'll lose a
friend along the way things will happen
and that's okay because you're strong
enough to make it better speech number
six is start taking action with Joo
willink I
guarantee that there are people on this
call that have been sitting on an idea
for more than a decade I guarantee it
sitting on a dream for over 10
years and that's
horrible that's where dreams die that's
where ideas die that's where projects
die
so how do you go about overcoming this
how do you actually go about overcoming
this and what you do is you take action
and listen the action doesn't need to be
huge you don't you you you probably
heard me say this I write a thousand
words a day when I got to write a book I
write a thousand words a day I don't
care if I write seven words in an hour I
write seven
words okay at least I tried and the next
day I'll write more but to do nothing to
write zero words the difference between
zero words and seven words is
infinite so you have to take some kind
of action this is what's cool right now
we're running the deaf reset and one of
the things on the deaf reset is to write
down the top three things you need to
do and then you go do those three
things that's why we have that in
there and you know I I I had this
conversation with Jordan Peterson like
imagine if you do what you're supposed
imagine if you wrote down the three
things you needed to do tomorrow and
then tomorrow you woke up and you did
them and then imagine if you did that
for a week and then imagine if you did
that for a year and then imagine if you
did that for 5 years where would you be
in
life totally different
place but that hardest step is that
first step to break the gravitational
pull break the gravitational pull
of stag
Nation so that's what we're going to do
we're going to take action now this is
also
important equally important is that when
you execute you have to pay attention to
the feedback
loop you have to pay attention when you
take action you have to pay attention to
the feedback that you then get is the
action that you took is it having the
desired effect that you want and this
seems so obvious it seems so so obvious
to say okay I took this action I'm
getting positive feedback I should do it
more that's great sometimes we take
action we don't get the feedback that we
want we realize maybe we're not on the
right path and instead of
adjusting we keep trying the same plan
we keep trying the same maneuver we keep
trying the same tactic even though it's
not
working and by the way that's something
that causes a lack of execution
because people think when they execute
that whatever they do is written in
stone and it's not nothing's written in
stone well just about nothing is written
in
stone if you if you're flexible if you
know you can change course if you know
you can adjust direction if you know you
can
adapt to a shifting Marketplace or a a
new Battlefield
scenario if you know if you go in with
an open mind and you know you can change
your mind and make adjustments then that
will make it easier for you to
[Music]
execute and that's why we talk about
utilizing the iterative decision making
process making small decisions taking
small actions execute those actions
swiftly and then adjust rapidly and
repeat and speech number seven the last
one before some very special bonus Clips
is just do it with Lisa Nichols and that
thing about your vision not everybody
can get your vision not everyone got
vision's Vision not everyone could see
this room not everyone could understand
but here's the thing I want you to walk
away with if everyone doesn't get your
vision it's because God didn't give your
vision to everybody God gave your vision
to you yes yes God gave you your vision
and you're the only one that have it
right here in your belly and your job is
to nurture that Vision your job is to
feed it with time to feed it with
training to feed it with coaches who are
20 to 30 steps Beyond you you're your
job is to give it what it needs so that
it can be birthed into the world so that
now your vision is our
reality that's your
job you came here impregnated with a
dream with a possibility and you're not
supposed to be comfortable until you set
it free and that's okay and then you
Lock and Load with people who are around
you this is a tribe I don't know if you
know this but this is a tribe this is a
community we help grow each other up
like Bish isn't it great how we watch
each other and say wow look at how we've
grown up we help grow each other up you
want to be around people who make you
stand on your tippy toes you want to be
around people make you want to be a
better woman cuz you're in their
presence make you want to be a better
man because you listen to their
conversation you was the way they father
you watch the way she wipes they make
you want to be a better human being cuz
you're in proximity with them yes
yes this is that
tribe love yourself enough to stay
connected to that tribe I used to think
my family was supposed to be my dream
catchers anybody else felt like that why
do they not get my dream cuz God didn't
give my dream to them God gave my dream
to
me you have your biological family and
they have a role in your life and then
you got your developed god-given family
and they have a role in your life and
you find your tribe because the last
thing you want to do is get to the final
chapter and say who could I have been
and what could I have
done and who could I have touched had I
given that dream a chance it's too late
now I can't get out the rocking chair
but man who would I have been the last
thing you want is to be left with
memories of things you didn't do do it
play Big Play Strong fly or fall just do
it yes yes just do
it
you have a single most important core
value and when you figure it out your
entire life changes if you feel like
you're being pulled in a million
different
directions you're walking on quick send
everybody wants something from you
you're hot and cold you want to do
something one day and then you don't the
other day you have a hard time saying no
to people and to Opportunities and
you're just being pulled in a thousand
directions does that sound familiar does
it sound like
you if that's
you you don't know what you stand for
because when you know what you stand for
all decisions become easier I wrote two
books on this your one word and then
built the serve and at the core of both
of them is figuring out what what do you
stand for what is your single most
important core value and when you can
name it when you can label it when you
can get to the root of it what it does
is give you Clarity for the rest of your
life mine is belief my one word is
belief
I want to believe in myself more and I
want to spread belief to the world to
the people around me it's why I make all
these videos I make them for myself
because I I need to learn and I want to
be around the best I want to be around
people who inspire me to believe more in
myself and I try to spread that to the
world it becomes a filter through which
I see the world it becomes the filter
through which my best self operates
whenever I don't know what to do
whenever I'm giv given an opportunity
whenever I might be pulled in a thousand
different
directions what do I run that through is
well believe what would the believe
version of Evan do what would he do and
then that just makes it easier boom
decision made
easier if you look at my YouTube Channel
people say well you do all these top 10
rules and you do all these inspiring
videos is great why not do top 10 of the
stupidest things this person said or top
10 reasons why not to follow this
person if I did that if I if I went
negative on Kanye West or Donald Trump
or
whoever those videos would actually do
better you know this is where it gets
really tough this is where it really
comes down to what do you stand for and
how much do you stand for because when
you can get to the core of who you are
that becomes a lot easier because making
those videos if I was to slam people
would do better people would much rather
watch negative videos than positive
people would much rather laugh at
somebody else than educate themselves
it's just just how we are we'd rather
watch Big Brother and watch reality TV
shows and people tearing each other
apart you you can't look away from a car
accident or fight on the street we have
this thing inside us where we like
seeing other people not doing well cuz
that's how we feel better about
ourselves when you see somebody else
struggling uh see someone else's
terrible life fun TV makes you feel
better about yourself so we have this we
have this insecurity inside all of us
and so those videos would do better top
10 stupidest things Kanye West has said
would would get more views would make me
more money would lead to more
subscribers would lead to all the
metrics that that you would probably
look at right you know if I look at well
what are my goals I want more
subscribers more views more comments
more Revenue it would help all of that
but it's anti-b belief I don't want I
feel gross I don't want to put that
content up I don't want to put up
content slamming people it's not who I
am it's not what makes me come
alive and this is where you could do it
for a short amount of time and you're
going to start to burn out because you
start to hate your life because you're
doing work that is just against who you
want to
be you look at Dave Hollis he's got his
one word of Captain great so what does a
captain
do Captain goes through choppy Waters
Captain is built for the rough Seas
so if he's ever stuck thinking about
should I do this or not well what would
a captain do and then boom
answer so figuring out your one word
figuring out that most important core
value what it does is give you a road
map for the rest of your life and it it
never gets old I will never stop
believing in myself and others and
wanting to continue to inspire Dave
Hollis will never stop wanting to be the
captain and you need to figure out what
yours is because that gives you
direction again for the rest of your
life so how do we do it how do what are
some of the tactics what are some of the
tricks that you can use because I think
this is one of the most important
exercises you can ever do in your life
understanding what you stand for as a
human it's not it's not taught you know
in schools it's not taught in in
textbooks most of the people who've
taught you in schools they're not happy
with the direction of their life either
right like as you start to get older
when you're when you're a kid and you
look at your parents and adults you feel
like they got it all figured out they
have the answers and then you realize
they have no idea what they're doing
like they're barely hanging on
themselves the teachers who taught you
about you know life in in school they're
not happy with their own life they
haven't figured this out either but I
think it's one of the most important
things that we can learn so again I have
two books on it you're one word built to
serve if you want to go deeper uh those
are great resources but you start with
what are some of the things that make
you come
alive you know who was your favorite
teacher growing up what movies did you
love growing up what did you love about
how your parents raised you even if you
hate your parents was there anything
that you can pull out that you loved and
what you're doing is looking at what are
some of the things that tie these things
together so if you had to write this is
the exercise I do with people okay tell
me your favorite movie and three words
to describe it tell me who your favorite
teacher was and three words to describe
them think think about your favorite
teacher growing up favorite coach your
favorite
Mentor it's not cuz they taught you
grade8 science right it wasn't the
material they taught you they made you
feel better as a human they they taught
you how to be a better person why what
did they do I was talking to a woman
yesterday coaching her through this
process we did an Instagram live
together she's part of my movement
makers program and just past a year
being in the program so we did a live
together and she wanted to go through
this exercise how do I find my one word
and her favorite teacher growing up
wasn't a teacher but was her coach it
was a track coach and one of the things
that she loved about the track coach was
he would get in and do it with
her so whenever she was tired whenever
she wanted to quit whenever she didn't
feel good enough he wouldn't just give
her words but he would do it with her he
he'd say okay I'll do the last one with
you race me he would run alongside her
so as you think about it what what was
your favorite teacher growing up who was
it and and why write down some
descriptive keywords what you'll find is
if you do that with who your favorite
mentors are who your favorite teachers
are what your favorite books or videos
are look at my Channel all the people we
profiled and who are the people that you
resonate with the most if you love me
what are three words about Evan caracle
that you love you love Dave Hollis what
are three words that describe Dave
Hollis you know all the good things that
that you love that make you feel alive
and bold and confident and servant and
wanting to help all those things are
connected but they don't feel connected
this is the problem this is the the
connective tissue work that you have to
do this is where we never learn these
things the things that you love are not
just random occurrences they're
connected when you write them down the
descriptive keywords you'll see a a
trend that happens between them so for
me it's Bel my favorite movie is Sea
Biscuit it's about a horse that's too
small and a jockey that that's too big
and a an a team owner that's going
bankrupt and somehow they come together
find each other and win all of these
races and it based off a true story and
they go and beat the the well-funded you
know the the team that has the perfect
jockey and the giant horse and the tons
of money and they go and they beat those
guys right so if I were to write down
you know the three words believe is on
there I might say Underdog um I might
say inspiring I might say believe I
would say believe
you know and then if I think about my
favorite teacher growing up Madame far
taught me French but I don't even use my
French like French isn't even that
valuable for the work that I do why do I
love Madame far well because she
believed in me because she would meet
with me once a week when I was in my uh
graduating year and she just asked me
about my life how I was doing in school
I was introverted I was shy you know it
was harder for me to make friends and um
feel like I fit in and belonged and so
for her I might put belong I would
definitely put believe and I might put
something else um maybe care or
compassion and those meetings with her
once a week turned me from a BC student
into a straight A student when I didn't
think that that was possible for for me
to do it because i' never really gotten
A's my entire School career
so we start to look at the the
similarities right but I'm far
believe you know compassion Etc seab
biscuit Underdog believe right there's
different keywords that will show up but
what's the consistent one
belief Ah that's
interesting it's interesting this keeps
coming up what would happen if I built
my whole life around belief what would
happen if I built my business through
belief what would happen if I created a
schedule and a calendar and habits and
routines that made me feel more belief
what would happen happen if I could
spread that belief to others what would
happen if I brought on team members who
loved believe and helped spread belief
with their skills and talents what would
happen if I had my significant other
believe in me right what would happen
What would how much has life change
Changes
Everything Changes Everything Everything
Changes because now I'm designing a life
with intent and purpose and with design
as opposed to randomly having things
experienced for me to me cuz everybody's
got an agenda for your time everybody
wants you to do certain
things and that's when you feel lost and
being pulled in million different
directions you have to figure out what
you stand for I think it's the most
important thing you can do as a human
what do you stand for what's your single
most important core value some people
get it right away from the exercises
some people it take some time and you
you you sit on it and it becomes more
and more right or more and more
wrong but when you find it and you get
that Compass you get that road map it's
with you for the rest of your life it
makes every decision easier it makes you
live a lot more in alignment and makes
you feel like what you're doing is
important that it matters it gives you
the confidence and the courage to do the
thing that you're afraid to do to step
outside your comfort zone to build the
business in the life that you want and
ultimately to make you
happy to make you
happy and then you can spread that
happiness to others and help them
believe in themselves
too because you made it this far in a
video I want to celebrate you most
people start and don't finish most
people never actually follow through
most people say they want something but
they don't ever do the work to actually
get it but you are different you are
special believe Nation you made it here
all all the way to the end and I love
you so as a special celebration if you
put a hasht believe down in the comments
Below on this video I will showcase you
and celebrate you somewhere on the
screen in a future video because you are
awesome if you want to never lack
motivation again check the video right
there next to me I think you'll love it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there I love it you know I love being
told no gotta it just means yes you know
to you yeah what turned you off lack of
enthusiasm really turns me off